the bare reality is that
Zelensky And everyone who leads him in
Washington in London in Brussels
unanimously firmly say that there is
no other basis for peace other than the
Zelensky formula. And the
Zelensky formula
I don’t even know, you can describe it in different ways,
but it is absolutely
not implementable  We simply won’t implement it and everyone
knows it.
But they say at the same time that this is the only
basis for negotiations and in general it is necessary to
defeat Russia on the battlefield. The
main reason why we left
this deal, it ceased to exist,
is that everything that was promised to us,
it all
turned out to be a deception.  I respect
the efforts of the Secretary General I
respect the efforts of Rebecca
Greensman General Jungstad they are
sincerely trying but not The return of
our main agricultural
Bank to the Swift system they are a solution to the
problems of
unhindered entry of Russian
ships into
Mediterranean ports, first of all but also
other European ones, not a solution to the problem of
insurances which  jumped four
times
and a whole series of other things,
we explained to the Secretary General
why his proposal cannot work,
we do not reject them, they simply do not
implement them and are the truth themselves. Write
next time